[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وانا رايه القاسم وهذه العربيه
وستون
البريطانيه وكيف تضغط على جرح بوتين القرن
بعد دعواتي تصنيفه ارهابيا في اوروبا
تقرير يكشف خبايا خليه الحرس الثوري
لاختيار اسرائيلينا في جورجيا
وترتيب الانتخابات والقاهره تعرض عليهم
تصورا اوليا للحل
وهتتابعونا معنا الليله ايضا
مع الاحتفالات بالعام القمري الجديد الصين
تواصل كسر حواجز الخوف من كرونه واقتصاد
العالم اكبر مست
[موسيقى]
فاده
ملف تصليح الغرب لاوكرانيا فالرئيس
الروسيه بلاديمي بوتين ندد بزياده امدادات
الاسلحه الغربيه لاوكرانيا وخلال اتصال
هاتفي مع نظيره التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
ودمر لنظامك اب الذي يراهن على تكثيف
الاعمال العزائيه من جهتي اكد اردوغان ان
تركيا استعده للعمل كوسيط لاحلال السلام
الدائم بين روسيا واوكرانيا
توعد باحراق الدبابات التي ينوي الغرب
وخاصه لندن ووارسو تسليمها لاوكرانيا
ان العمليه العسكريه الخاصه ستستمر وان
الدبابات ستحترق وتحترق وشدد ديسكو بعض
الدول الغربيه لتغير الوضع على الارض بل
ستطيل الحرف فقط
وبتزامل نقلت قناه سي ان ان عن مصادر
استخباراتيه امريكيه قولها ان الحرب
الاوكرانيه تقدمت فرصه ثمينه للجيش
الامريكي والحلفاء الغربيين لاختبار اسلحه
لا يمكن تجريبها الا في حاله الحرب وقالت
المصادر الاستخباراتيه ان اوكرانيا تعد
فعلا مختبرا حربيا بكل ما تعنيه الكلمه من
معنى لحرب واقعيه بين دولتين صناعيتين
امريكا وروسيا
استخدمت مسيرات رخيصه الثمن وذات فاعليه
على الارض في اشاره الى مسيرات ايران
نتحاول الان الى الوضع على الارض فوصل
التركيز الشديد على جبهتي سوليدار وبخموطه
قال حاكم مدينه سيفاستون في شبه جزيره
القرم
اندفاعات الجويه الروسيه اسقط ثلاثه
طائرات مسيره فوق السياره
بالحرب على ابقاء الضغط على القمه الاجابه
تبدا من الرئيس بوتن فحاكم الكريم المتهم
من الغرب بالسعي لاعاده امجاد الاتحاد
السوفيتي تمثل له القرم نقطه ضعف واضحه
فمصيرها الى حد كبير مرتبط بمصيره السياسي
تلك الجزيره لا طالما بقيت بعيده عن
الصواريخ والانفجارات حتى تحول مسار الحرب
بين روسيا واوكرانيا بعد سته اشهر من
انديلاها تحديدا ما وقع عشيه قمه الفيفا
في اغسطس الماضي ولم يكن في حسبان موسكو
حينها ان كافر لا تدافع عن نفسها فقط
وانما تهدف الانتزاع القرمي مجددا فهي في
نظر كل منهما
مده تلك الليله استوى على روسيا اوكرانيا
تلعب بالنار بل وتدحرج كورتها بضرب القمه
تلك الجزيره التي يصفها بوتن بان كل شيء
فيها يتحدث عن تاريخ روسيا وفخرها
[موسيقى]
اقواله عن القرم ليش هذا الهمم ويدعم
معنويات الروس يقول انها في قلوب الناس
وعقولهم كانت القرمود دائما جزء لا يتجزا
من روسيا لكن الرئيس الاوكراني
اساسا لانتهاء هذه الحرب باسرها مثل ما
خصص كلمته في بدايه العام على المنطقه
قائلا ان الحرب بدات بشبه جزيره القرمه
وستنتهي بها متعهدا استعادتها خطاب لم
يلقى اذان الروس الذين ما زالوا يعتبرون
ان اكياس تعيش اوهام استعاده القرمي
فانتاعها من بوتن هو خط احمر وقد يمثل
نهايه نظام وليس فقط نهايتها حرب صحيفه
الامريكيه لخصت الموضوع استعاده القمه
تعني نهايه بوتنا
تتابع الصحيفه في مقالها نقلا عن مايكل
كيماج استاذ التاريخ بالجامعه الكاثوليكيه
الامريكيه ان خساره القرم ستبعد احساسا
مريبا لدى الروس بان بوتن غير قادر على
اداره الامور
وستضعفه بالتاكيد سياسيا يتفق معه محارب
قديم في البحريه الامريكيه يدعى شونس
ويؤكد ان مصيره بوتنه قد يكون اسوء من
فقدان وظيفته اذا سقطت شبه جزيره القرد في
ايدي اوكرانيا
في نظر البعض فقد يفكر الاوليغارش في
التخلص من بوتن اذا لم يستجب لدعوات
التنحي بعد سقوط القمه في كلا الحالتين
سيؤدي الامر الى هلاكه على احد تعبير
لديها ممتلكات باهظه كالفنادق والمنتجعات
والقوارب والمنازل والشركات حتى روسيا
الدوله نفسها ضخت مبالغ ضخمه لبناء الطرق
والجسور والموانئ فهذه الجزيره والحفاظ
عليها يعتبران كمتحانا يجب ان يجتازه بوتن
ولا فرصه للرسوب
[موسيقى]
لكن ما الذي يفعله بوتن او قد يفعله
لتفادي هذا السيناريو او الكابوس يا طاهر
اذا فقد القرم سيدخل في ورطه و لكي لا يقع
في مازق خساره القرن فليس بعيدا ان يذهب
لاكثر السيناريوهات تطرفا ونقصد هنا ان
يلوح بشبح النووي حتى لا تسقط من بين يديه
فلماذا كل هذا الاهتمام بالقرب انها اولا
وقبل كل شيء بؤره استراتيجيه عسكريه وجيو
سياسيا بالنسبه لروسيا منذ قرون وحينما
قررت بدا عمليتها العسكريه اعتبرتها
بمثابه نقطه انطلاق في الجنوب لغزل
اوكرانيا في فبراير الماضي وتبلغ مساحتها
27,000 كلم مربع وتطل على بحر ازوف وعلى
البحر الاسود ولا يفصلها عن روسيا شرقا
سوا الذي دفع بوتين من اجل بنائه اربعه
مليارات دولار اما مدينه سيفست بول في
القرن فهي موطن لميناء رئيسي يطيح لموسكو
الوصول الى البحر الابيض المتوسط وهي
المقر الرئيسي لاسطول البحر الاسود الروسي
والاهم ان سيفستوبول تحتوي على ملجا شيد
بالعهد السوفيتي تحسبا من ضربه امريكيه
وصفها القائد سوفيتي جوزيف ستالين بانها
حامله الطائرات التي لا يمكن اغراقها وليس
ببعيد ان يقول عنها قائد بحري في القرن
التاسع عشر ان من يملك بول يملك البحر
الاسود
رمزا ثلاثيا للسلطه والهويه
وبما ان اهميتها تعود للعهد الامبراطوري
فالاستيلاء على شبه جزيره القرم يعني ان
بامكانها ان تمر بم الباسفور الى حوض
البحر الابيض المتوسط وبالتالي الوصول الى
شمال افريقيا وجنوبي اوروبا
تهديد لاوروبا باسرها وللاستقرار العالمي
لا يمكن ان تكون منطقه البحر الاسود مكانا
امنا والقرم المحتله لا يمكن ان يكون هناك
سلام واستقرار دائما البلدان المطله على
البحر الابيض المتوسط بينما تمتلك روسيا
القدره على استخدام شبه الجزيره كقاعده
عسكريه
لهاضعنا في اخر التطورات اهلا بك محمد
يعني الروايه الروسيه تتحدث الان عن
السيطره على سوليدار واستهدافات في بخموت
وايضا في خرسون ماذا تقول الروايه
الاوكرانيه
نعم مساء الخير وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
حتى هذه اللحظه قبل ساعه كان هناك التقرير
المسائلي هيئه الاركان في وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه اكدت ان القوات الاوكرانيه لا
تزال تقاتل في اكثر من منطقه في بلده
سوليدار وان يعني الطريق بين السوليدار
وبخموت لا يزال تحت السيطره القوات
الاوكرانيه التي تستطيع حتى هذه اللحظه
ولديها القدره على ايصال
والمواد اللوجستيه والاسلحه والذخائر وحتى
فرق لتساند القوات الاوكرانيه الى داخل
بلده سوليدار وهكذا يعني بهذه الطريقه
تنفي وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه سيطره روسيا
بشكل كامل على باخمن وحتى يعني ايضا وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه بدات تقول انك قواتها
اصبحت مسيطره بشكل كامل على شمال مدينه
بشكل قاطع يعني المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاوكراني في قطاع الجمباز سر جيش وفاته
الذي اكد يعني في مداخله مع احد القنوات
الاوكرانيه قبل ساعتين ان الجيش الاوكراني
لديه استراتيجيه مختلفه عما يعني عن وضعيه
القتال في همم في مناطق اخرى الجيش
الاوكراني لا يزال يحافظ على بعض مراكزه
الاساسيه داخل وسط وجنوبي والشرق وغربي
بلده سوليدار وايضا القوات الاوكرانيه في
البلده يعني التاليه بعد السويدار وهي
سيفر التي القوات الروسيه قامت اليوم
بقسوها بشكل عنيف ولكن مع ذلك همم محمد
الى ما تعزل قوات الاوكرانيه هذا تاخر همم
هذه الانتكاسه فيهاتين المنطقهتين تحديدا
بعد كل الانجازات التي قامت بها القوات
الاوكرانيه هل من تحميل مسؤوليات في ما
بين التراتبيات المختلفه في الجيش او في
القوات عامه همم او من مراجعات او من
تغييرات همم تكتيكيه وفي المناصب
يعني لا حتى هذه اللحظه يعني لا يوجد اي
لا يوجد اي حديث عن انتعار او بعض
الخلافات او تحميل مسؤوليه لضباط في وضع
ما حصل في بلده سوليدات ولكن الجيش
الاوكراني يقول انه يسعى في بلده لوليدارو
ومحيطها الى استنزاف مجموعات فاجنر ويكون
الجيش الاوكراني انه حتى هذه اللحظه تم
استجابه اكثر من 70% من وحدات واعداد
القتل بالمئات كما يعني تقول دائما وبشكل
مستمر نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني هانم
مليار التي اكد ان القوات الروسيه تتلقى
خسائر بشريه كبيره جدا وان وعندما تحاول
القوات الروسيه للتقدم داخل بلده سوليدر
هي مضطره لان تدوس على جثث جنود الروس
القتل الذين قتلوا في العمليات يعني الجيش
الاوكراني يقول انه يسعى الاستنزاف القوات
الروسيه لانه روسيا
حشدت كل طاقتها للسيط على الرجال ومنها
الانطلاق الى نقطتين وهي بخمس يعني ما
تقوله القوات الاوكرانيه ان لديها
استراتيجيه مغيره ولكن الجيش الاوكراني
قبل حوالي اربعه اشهر كان يطالب باسلحه
وعتاد ودبابات ونقلاب جون ويستغل والجيش
الاوكراني هذه الفتره وما يحصل في دار
لايصال رساله الى الشركاء الغربيين ان
اوكرانيا بالفعل بحاجه الى دبابات الى
ناقلات الى منظومات صواريخ والى دعم عسكري
للقوات البريه لانكران يكون ما حصل عليه
هو لا يشكل جزء من 10% ما تحتاجه صحته
محمد يعني اليوم كان هناك منورات روسيه
بلا روسيه وتدريبات تكتيكيه ما صداها فيك
يعني هناك كلام كبير وخوف كبير ويعني وضع
الحدود الروسيه الاوكرانيه البلار روسيه
هناك يعني وضع خطر في تلك الفتره خاصه
المدورات التي تقوم بها روسيا بالاشتراك
مع بيلاروسيا وان عدنا الى الذاكره هي
المرحله يعني نفس المناورات حصلت قبل
اجتياح الاراضي الاوكرانيه وتقدم القوات
الروسيه عبر الحدوث البيلاروسيا الى تركيا
بيانات حول وضع الحدود مع
بيلاروسيا خاصه مقاطعه
الفوفونين وايضا مقاطعه ان الجيش
الاوكراني يستعد لاي سيناريو قد يحصل في
تركيا شكرا جزيلا لك محمد البابا صحفيه من
كيف تحياتنا اليك
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون معنا في العربيه 360 ايضا في
مقابله مع العربيه رئيس وزراء باكستاني
دول الخليج ويؤكد انه ساهم في تقليل
الاعضاء الاقتصاديه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في الملف الايراني مطالب
بادراج الحرس الثوري على قائمه الجماعات
الارهابيه في اوروبا تكتسب زخاما جديدا
الالاف من ابناء الجاليه الايرانيه تجمعوا
في ستراسبورغ شرقي فرنسا من اجل حتى دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي على الاتحاد الخطوات
يبحث فرضا حزمه عقوبات جديده ضد طهران بعد
عمليات الاعدام والتورط في الحرب
الاوكرانيا
امام مقر البرلمان الاوروبي وذلك للمطالبه
بادراج الحرس الثوري الايراني على لائحه
المنظمات الارهابيه للاتحاد الاوروبي
ويشارك في هذا التحرك متظاهرون من حوالي
50 مدينه اوروبيه بتوقيت هذه التظاهره
ايضا يتزام مع اجتماعا للبرلمان الاوروبي
للبحث في سبل فرد عقوبات جديده على ايران
بعد الاعدامات الاخيره وسيحضره ايضا
السياسه الخارجيه للاتحاد الاوروبي
المتظاهرون اطلقوا هتافات مؤيده
للاحتجاجات في ايران
ضد الجمهوريه الاسلاميه في ايران وكذلك
حملوا رسائل موجهه الى البرلمانيين
الاوروبيين كتب عليها كونوا صوتنا وماذا
تنتظرون بعد لاضافه الحارس الدوري
الايراني على لائحه المنظمات الارهابيه
هذه التظاهره لن تكون الاخيره لكن
المتظاهرين هنا يعولون على اهميتها والضغط
الذي تشكله على القاده الاوروبيين لمنع
نصب المزيد من المشانق في ايران فذهوك
العربيه
[موسيقى]
هذا هو اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الالمانيه
استدعاء السفير الايراني للمره الثانيه
خلال اسبوع بسبب عمليات الاعدام التي
تنفذها بلاده واوضح متحدث باسم الخارجيه
الالمانيه ان الخطوه جاءت بسبب مخاوف
برلينا بشان سجل طهران في مجال حقوق
الانسان
محاوله اغتيال رجل اعمال اسرائيلي في
جورجيا في نوفمبر الماضي ووصلت الى ان
المتهمين هم اعضاء القدس التابعي للحرس
الثوري الايراني
خطوه وتخطيط ومحاولات اغتيال انشطه لا
يمكن عنوانتها الى تحت مظله تنظيمات
ارهابيه
في نوفمبر الماضي والتي كانت محاوله
اغتيال لرجل اعمال اسرائيلي في ارضها يكشف
الستار اليوم عن منافذها ايران
انترناشونال في تقرير حصري نشرت اسماء
والصور المتهمين بتنفيذ المحاوله حامد عبد
الله محمد رضا
ليس مواطنين ايرانيين عاديين بل العناصر
في فرق القدس التابعي للحرس الثوري
الايراني وتحديدا في الوحده 4
مخطط صممه الفيلقو ليدير العمليه في عده
دول ويستعين بفريق ان يرتبط بالقاعده لجمع
المعلومات
كانت بقياده حسين رهبان الذي تشير
المعلومات الى تلقيه التعليمات مباشره من
اللواء حمد عبد الله وهو قائد وحده فيلق
القدس 400 والذي كان نائب قاسم سليماني
يتزمن التقرير الذي نشرته ايران انترنال
مع طرح اوروبي لوضع الحرس الثوري على
قائمه المنظمات الارهابيه مشروع قرار
فرنسي الماني قد يضم عددا من دول الاتحاد
في اطار السياسه الامنيه خاصه بالتكتل جاء
على خلفيه اعدام عدد من المتظاهرين في
الحركه الشعبيه الحالي في ايران الى ان
محاولات الاختيار المنظمه قد تزيد امكانيه
التحول مشروع الى قرار فعلي استنادا
للقوانين والاعراف الدوليه
ايفا عمر العربيه
اهلا بك معنا صالح الى اي مدى الحرس
الثوري الايراني مستقل بذاته في هكذا
قرارات وفي تنفيذ هكذا اغتيالات او
محاولات اغتيال ام انه ااه يعني هناك
ترابيه معينه بحيث يعرض مثل هذه القرارات
او هذه الاسماء على المخابرات على الرئيس
او على خميره مباشره
نعم يعني كما هو معروف يعني فيلق القدس هو
ذراع العمليات الخارجيه للاثاث للحرس
الثوري وجهاز
هذه ياخذ اوامره مباشره من المرشده على
وينسق بذلك عن طريق نجده مستوى خامني
الوحده 400 التي ذكر اسمها في التقرير همم
هي المتخصصه بالاحتيالات الخارجيه همم هذه
السنه الاخيره انها همم جاء همم في سياق
التهديدات الايرانيه ضد اسرائيل على خلفيه
همم
محسن فكري زاده همم الذي كان مسؤول عن
الشرق العسكري في البرنامج انه الايراني
وضرب اهداف النوويه وبعض المواقع العسكريه
الايرانيه همم بالتاكيد هذه الاجهزه
اعطيها لبعض ما يمكن همم نقول انها مستقله
او انها تعمل بمفردها لذلك الان هناك
مطالبات بادراج كل الحرس الثوري ك- تنظيم
في الواقع يهيمن على
المفاصل
السياسيه والعسكريه
الاقتصاديه في داخل البلاد هذا القرار اذا
من قبل الدول الاوروبيه او الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا هيكون له تاثيره كبيره
همم ليس فقط في شان القدرات هذا الجهاز بل
همم تاثير كلي على النظام وادائيه
على اي اساس وباي ترتبيه توضع الاولويه في
الاسماء ومن الاسماء المعروفه من قاده
الحارس الثوري وفيلق القدس الفاعلين
باتخاذ القرار
يعني الاسم المعروف هو في وسائل الاعلام
اللواء حامد عبد الله المصنف منذ عام 2011
على لائحه العقوبات الامريكيه بسبب بروج
اسمه في ملف اغتيال عادل الجبير وزير
الخارجيه السعودي السابق عندما كان سفيرا
في الولايات المتحده همم ورد اسمه
لهذه العمليه ايضا ارتبط اسمه همم عده
محاولات في همم اغتيالات اهداف غربيه
وايضا ااه اهداف اسرائيليه همم الشخص
الاخر هو حسين رهبان الذي كان همم يشرف
على هذه العمليه في جورجيا همم هذه الوحده
اساسا من قبل قاسم سليماني ومن قبل الضباط
الذين كانوا من ابناء مدينتهم
وكانوا معه في
ايرانيه الثمانينات
وتكونت لتكون همم ذراع الاغتيالات في
الخارج وهذا يثبت بوضوحا النظام الايراني
كيف يستخدم الارهاب والاغتيالات لتحقيق
اغراض سياسيه لذلك الان المطالبه
بتصنيف الحرس الثوري كما منظمه الارهابيه
باشا امرا ملحا لانه هذا استمرار حركه
داخل باعتقادك هو الذي يؤثر في الدفع قدما
باتجاه تصنيف الحارس الثوري ارهابيا
اوروبيا همم واذا حصل ذلك
مدى التاثير همم العكسي على الداخل على
هذا الحرك
يعني لحد الان الحراره حصلت انجازات كبيره
منها وقت
المفاوضات مع النظام الاي
راني يا ذات له منها وقصه فقط تجاريه منها
تغيير سياسه الدوليه تجاه ايران بعدما
كانت سياسه تعتمد على مبدا التراضي
للنظام واعطاء الامتيازات والتنازلات
الوفاء الان تتجه الدول الاوروبيه
وبريطانيا والولايات المتحده وكندا الى
اسماء صوت شارع ايران واليوم كان هناك
120,000 ايراني تجمع من كل انحاء تراسبور
امام العربيه ليقولوا ان هذا الارهاب لم
يعد يختصر على ابناء الشعب الايراني في
الداخل
وانا خلايا مثل خليه اسد الله اسدي التي
اراد تفجير مؤتمر المعارضه هناك نشاطات
يعني
في اوكرانيا ضد الشعب الاوكراني في مناطق
عديده وهذه هذه المنظمه لم تعد خبر على
الايراني على الامن الاقليم يودوني شكرا
الايراني
[موسيقى]
بسبب دعم دول الخليج واوضح رئيس وزراء
باكستان انه يتم العمل على تطوير التعاوني
في ما جلي التجاره والاستثمارات الخليج
مصارعه باكستان وريحان وهام
الدعم الملموس والقيم جدا من الدول
الشقيقه في الخليج وليس هناك ادنى شك في
ذلك سواء كان من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
او الامارات العربيه المتحده
اندفاع قوي والقدره على الصمود والشجاعه
وفي المقابله الخاصه التي اجرتها الزميله
ليال لاختيار اشاد رئيس الوزراء
الباكستاني بالقياده الديناميكيه لولي
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
السعودي
تحت قياده الشيخ محمد بن زايد الرمال الى
ذهب وكيف اصبح المجتمع السعودي من اكثر
الشعوب العالميه ازدهار تحت هذه القياده
الديناميكيه لاخي صاحب السمو الملكي
الامير محمد بن سلمان
الشيء الاهم هو الالتزام والجهود المستمره
والتضحيات
الخطابات ملهمه ولكن الكلام يجب ان يتحول
الى عمل هذا كل شيء
[موسيقى]
عبد الله
في ليبيا
اللجنه العسكريه السلامه
السكيورتي بوب بروسيس
لام
بالكويت
السلام
القوات المسلحه
وبالتزامل مع اجتماعات سر تلك كشفت مصادر
لقناه العربيه تفاصيل اجتماع القاهره الذي
جمع اطراف ليبيا حيث طلب قائد الجيش
الليبي خليفه حفتر بضروره توحيد المؤسسه
العسكريه
بشكل تدريجي
على ابعاد المتطرفين وذوي الاحكام
الجنائيه
وليس حكومتين
التي ابرمتها حكومه دبي
وطرحها للاستفتاء الشعبي فيما بعد القاهره
تصورا مبدايا
مصر دائما الانخراط في مسارات الحل وجهود
خفض التصعيد بين الاطراف الليبيه وهذا وقع
يفرده الجوار وتفرده الحدود المشتركه
والامور المتعلقه بالاستقرار الامني داخل
الحدود المصريه والذي يتاثر بما يحدث خارج
هذه الحدود
هناك مصالح اقتصاديه مشتركه بين البلدين
تتعطل في حاله عدم الاستقرار لذا فان
استقرار ليبيا قد يشكل طوق نجاه بالنسبه
للصادرات المصريه وكذلك للعماله المصريه
ويحقق ليبيا ما تصبوا اليه من اعاده اعمار
وتوفر بضائع رخيصه نسبيا مصر تسعى للتاكد
من ان الحله السياسيه في ليبيا مملوكا
بصفه حصريه لليبيين لذلك فهي دائمه الدعم
لاركان الدوله الوطنيه المختلفه وتعلي
اهميه عدم التدخل الخارجيه في الشؤون
الليبيه وعليه فلديها عدد من الثوابت
تتعلق وخروج المرتزقه واي تواجد عسكريه
غير شرعي
انهاء وجود الجامعات الارهابيه
مصر تحرس دائما على التوصل لحلول توافقيه
عن طريق استضافه اجتماعات الليبيه الراميه
للوصول لمثل هذه الحلول وكثيره ما تطرح
صيغ توافقيه في حاله تماسك كل طرف بما
لديه
مصر تحتضن خليفه حفتر وعجله صالح ومحمد
الوفي بالتالي هناك اجتماعات همم مكثفه
جدا وهناك سياسه مصريه مكثفه جدا بالنسبه
للملف الليبي هناك همم شبه قبول من معظم
الاطراف الليبيه
بمثل هذه السياسه المصريه فيما عدا عبد
الحميد او حكمه الوحده الوطنيه
همم لبعض السياسيين همم انها همم
لحاجه المواطن اللي هي لاغراض شخصيه او
لاطاله عمرهم في مصر السياديه عشر سنوات
همم نتفرجوا على الاجتماعات هذه بتصير يتم
اجرائها من قبل همم
تقريبا نفس المواضيع و بدون اي نتائج
فبراي احنا في ليبيا محتاجين في تغيير
الشخوص
اكثر من اعاده تدويره
في ليبيا ليبيا ما شاء الله يعني مفيش شيء
يمنعهم انهم يجتمعوا في ليبيا هم كلهم
ليبيا مع اطراف خليجيه
تتابعون معنا في العربيه 360 ايضا هل
غداره الارض باصحابها في الغوطه الشرقيه
ام غدر بهما طرف ثالث
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد فعليا لم يتعافى العالم
بعد كليا من جائحه كورونا ومازال يناور
امام الفيروس باللقاحات والتطعيمات
المعززه اي ان الفايروس موجود بيننا و
بعباره اخرى نكاد نتعايش مع وجوده وحتى مع
متحولاته لكن الصين والتي قيل قبل ثلاث
سنوات انها من نشرت الوباء من وهران
البقره الاولى للمرض فقد سم اهلها من
سياسه صفر كوفد صارمه واخيرا رفعت تلك
السياسه الصفريه الجافه على صدورهم في
مطلع ديسمبر وباتو وكانهم استسلموا
الانتشار الفايروس او ربما قرروا مواجهته
مهما كلف الامر ومهما اكتظت المستشفيات
بالمرضى
حتى ان منظمه الصحه العالميه شكرت شفافيه
الصين حينما اعلنت انها وبعد التخلي عن
سياستها سجلت 60,000 وفاه خلال خمسه
اسابيع كما رصدت اصابه نحو 900 مليون شخص
بالفيروس منذ الحادي عشر من يناير الجاري
اذا نتحدث عن هذه الاصابات بالارقام
الصادمه والتي لم تمنع الصين من الاستعداد
للاحتفال بعام الارنب وفقه التقويم الصيني
وبات المواطنون يتهيئون للاستقبال السنه
القمريه الجديده احتفالات مبهجه تضيء
المدن الصينيه وكان الوباء لم يعصف بها
يوما فلا مكان للحزن بين هذه الالوان
الزاهيه وان كانت العدوى ستتفشى بينهم
مجددا اختاروا المواجهه اذا كما هو حال
ملايين صينيين الذين [__] القطارات
والطائرات من اجل السفر الى قراهم لقضاء
عطله راس السنه القمريه الجديده من دون
فرد قيود صحيه على المسافرين
واحد فاصل اربعه مليار نسمه عدد هائل
تقريبا مليار ونصف كلهم اجتمعوا على رفض
القيود لكنهم سيدفعون الضريبه حتما خاصه
اذا لم تكن الخطوه مدروسه بما فيه الكفايه
فالهجره الكبيره للعمال من المدن الى مسقط
راسهم لزياره العائلات ستؤدي الى انتشار
العدوى في المناطق الريفيه الاقل تجهيزا
بالخدمات الطبيه كالرعايه المركزه واجهزه
التنفس الصناعي
[موسيقى]
اذا من الواضح ان المرحله القادمه
منذ تخليها عن السياسه الصفريه بلغت الذره
والتفش الفايروس في اقرب وقت من المتوقع
بعيدا عن الاسهم والبورصه يتوقع البنك
الدولي نموا بنسبه 4 فاصل اربعه هذا العام
بالنسبه للصين يقول محللون اقتصاديون ان
المستهلكين الصينيين راك من خلال الحجر في
المنازل مدخراتهم
لثلاث سنوات وحان الوقت الان ليستمتع بها
بعد هذه السنوات العجاف حيث ارتفعت ارصده
البنوك الاسريه بنسبه 42
بالمئه او اربع فاصل ثمانيه تريليون دولار
منذ بدايه عام 2020
علامات ذلك بدات تظهر جليا في توافق
السياحه الصينيين والوجهتان الاكثر
استفاده منهم هما تايلاند وهم كونج اما
المدينه التي يفضلها معظم الصينيين هي لوس
انجلوس في كاليفورنيا
وتتمتع بشعبيه عاليه بينهم ووافقه محركات
البحث فان التفتيش عنها تضاعف في الفتره
الاخيره اضافت الصحيفه ان شركه طيران
صينيتين هما التشاينا نعم ايرلاينز تخططان
الاستئناف الخدمه اليوميه بدون توقف بين
بكين و لوس انجلوس هذا الشهر ومن المتوقع
ان يصل ما يقرب من مليون زائر صيني الى
الولايات المتحده هذا العام ارتفاع من
359,000 العام الماضي وفقا لجمعيه السفر
الامريكيه
وسف- سافر الصهيونيون او لا فان الانفاق
الاستهلاكي لن يقتصر على قطاع السياحه لان
الموجودين سيختارون تار فيها انفسهم
والعوده الى وجبات المطاعم المحليه
والافلام والاحداث الرياضيه وغيرها من
الانشطه الشخصيه التي كانت محظوره اثناء
عمليه الاغلاق بهذا الانفاق مشاهدينا هناك
عده علامات تجاريه امريكيه ستستفيد وعلى
راسها ستاربكس ويمبرانس ملكه سلسله مطاعم
كنتاكي الشهيره وغيرها وغيرها الكثير
[موسيقى]
وانضم الينا من بكين اصبح في النادر اهلا
بك سيد نادر يعني هل بدات تظهر تداعيات
رفع قيود الاغلاق التي عزلت الصين لثلاث
سنوات بسبب رائحه كورونا اتحدث عن الناحيه
الاجتماعيه وايضا الاقتصاديه
اه اهلا ومرحبا بكم طبعا يعني في الفتره
الاخيره وخاصه
الاصبعين على خيران
بدات مدن صينيه كبيره مثل الباكين
واخرى يعني
العوده الى
يعني قبل قرون يعني هناك انتاج قويه
وهناك ايضا همم الاستحار اسحار وكذلك
استحام في الطرق
يعني يمكن ان نراه هذه شعر
في القوي للاقتصادي همم
الاقتصاد الصيني وكذلك اللي همم
عوده الانشئتها الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه الى طبيعتها
هذا بالنسبه الى التعافي الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي ولكن الى اي مدى هذا ينعكس
تعافيا من كورونا نفسها مع التسجيل
الاصابات المرتفعه جدا والوفيات المرتفعه
جدا ايضا في الصين ولذلك قد يعني يتسائل
بعض اذا ما كان من الحكمه بمكان رفع
القيود كليا في الصين
طبعا همم لقد تجاوزت في الوقت الحالي همم
دور الانتشار همم لكرون في مدن صينيه
الكبيره وكذلك حاليا بوضع يعني مستقر تحت
السيد حره وطبعا هناك همم زياده السريعه
لاعداد المصابين وكذلك هناك ضغوط على
المستشفى
مرحله فلابد ان تمر بها اي دوله في العالم
عند بدايه رفع البيوت
هنا في الصين الوضع كما كنت همم تحت
السيطره ومستقيرا ومعظم
مصابين وهمم يعني لا يحتاجون الى الذهاب
الى المستشفى
من ان تزداد العدوى وتتفشى مع همم يعني
زياره الاهل في ياض فيما هناك مناطق
بعينها غير مجهزه تماما كالمدن
همم طبعا همم هناك همم
الحكومه تعمل على توفير الخدمات التدريبيه
وكذلك يعني موارد طبيه في المناطق الريفيه
همم حتى الان همم لم نشهد همم هناك
الزياده السريه
للعدد المصابين في المناطق الريفيه لان هم
يعني في المناطق يعني همم
عزل الشيب شبه العزل ولا يوجد اتصال كثير
همم
[موسيقى]
في المناطق الريفيه فل هم حتى الان لم
اصابهمرون ليس مثلنا في المدن الثانيه
كبيره يعني
اتجاه العديد من الصينيين الى السفر الى
الخارج بسبب ارتفاع طبيعه الحال المدخرات
بالسنوات الثلاث هل هناك من قيود تضعها
السلطات الصينيه على السفر الى الخارج او
ربما
محاذير معينه
حتى حاليا نحن في سوريا
يعني
تناقل ولا يوجد اي بيوت على السفر وتناكل
وحتى الى الخارج وهناك الحكومه تشجع على
الشركات والمؤسسات على الذهاب الى الخارج
اللي همم
الاستئناف الزيارات الى الخارج وكذلك
الصين الان خاصه القادمين من الصين السيد
نادر همم اشرح لنا باختصار كيف اختلفت
حياتك شخصيا همم اثناء سياسه صفر كوفيت في
الصين وبعد رفع هذه السياسه
ااه نعم انا ايضا في خلال الثلاث سنوات
الماضيه قبل الانفتاح قبل التحسين هذه
الاجراءاتك انا علي ان اذهب اينما اريد ان
اذهب الى اماكن عامه
لابد او خاصه في هذا العام
نتيجه سلبيه للاختبار
حاليا
انما اذهب الى الخارج همم يعني خارج
المنزل لا بد اح احم ال- همم الهاتف لانها
فيها الجميع والمعلومات
واخشى ان همم يعني انساها في البيت لان لا
استطيع
اي مكان بدونها ولكن حاليا لا اخش اي شيء
اذهب الى المكان
الى اي مكان اريد
شكرا لك شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]
اعلنت قوات الدرك في ايطاليا اعتقال
الهارب رقم واحد في البلاد واحد اخطر
زعماء المافيا
ديمارو وذلك يا طاهر بعد 30 عاما من
الفرار حيثما القبض عليه وهو يخضع لعلاج
في عياده خاصه بجزيره صقليه تحت اسم
المستعار
وحده خاصه من قوات الدرك الايطالي
الكرفينياري القات القبض على هذا الستيني
نحيل البنيان في مدينه باليرمو بجزيره
صقليه ناقل المافيا الاشهر
زعيم عصابه كوسان
دينارو الملقب بديابوليك او الشيطاني
اختبا من العداله منذ 30 عاما بعد ارتكابه
سلسله من الجرائم التي اوصلته لتصدر لائحه
اكثر المطلوبين للعداله الايطاليه
انتقلت شخصيا لجزيره صقليه لتشكر مسؤولي
القضاء والشرطه على هذا الانجاز الذي
وصفته بانتصار للدوله
نسينا دينارو ابتدا مسيرته الاجراميه في
مطلع الثمانينات من القرن الماضي كاتل
ماجور بسيط الى عام
1993 حيث شارك في التخطيط وتنفيذ سلسله من
التفجيرات التي استهدفت قضاه وسياسيين
ايطاليين واودت بحياه العشرات
وكان الهدف منها هو ارهاب الحكومه
الايطاليه لتطلق سراحه زعيم المافيا انا
ذاك سلفادور ريرينا وعددا من معاونه فشلت
حمله التفجيرات في ارغام الحكومه
الايطاليه على اطلاق سراح رجال المافيا
المسجونين فاختفى مسينا دينارو
لثلاثه عقود الى ان القي عليه القبض في
مستشفى في ثقل المياه العربيه
[موسيقى]
كره اليوم في العربيه 360 من سوريا
وتحديدا من الغوطه الشرقيه
من اهوال مع الحرب السوريه
لكن تركت الذكر الاليمه على قدم الزوج
الارض فبينهما وبينها الفت وعهد لكن من
غدر هو من زرع علقم دون ان يكترث بمن
سيدوس عليه
وفي تصريح اليوم
المد لا يرفع جميع السفن وانما يرفع
اليهود الفارهه فقد هذا التصريح لمن يطهر
عماله انتقدت التخفيضات الضريبيه للاغنياء
على مستوى العالم
وطلبت المنظمه بالتضامن مع انطلاق مؤتمر
دافوس بالغاء الثروات المتراكمه على المدى
الطويل
حجه المنظمه واضحه فمن بين كل 100 دولار
جديده تم تحقيقها في السنوات ال 10
الماضيه ذهب ذهب 54 دولارا لواحد في المئه
من البشر وتحديدا لاكثر اغنياء هذا الكوكب
وفي فيديو اليوم حادث غريب حيث اصطدمت
سياره مسرعه ببوابه الشهيره في العاصمه
الالمانيه برلين البوابه التي
كانت بعدها رمزا لتوحيد والوحده لم تكن
كذلك للسائق السياره على
الاقلباسات الحادثه مجهوله حتى الان
[موسيقى]